there's people on telly that have been
accused of a rape there's been there's
been people on telly that have been
accused of it there's been there's been
footballers and this whole rhetorical
thing you're doing it again no because
this whole rhetoric of it ruins men's
lives it's hard to believe when you're
seeing men go off living living Prof
like profitable lives after that's
happened to them or they were were they
were they prosecuted or were they
accused well they were accused but this
is what I'm saying okay but see there
there you go again if you've never got
the evidence because it's my words
against theirs okay but you this is just
this is just this is just where you're
going back to you just believe women
without evidence and that's and I and
these are and then and then listen
listen and then this
you don't even know them so you can't
even make the argument the case you just
made where you said there are
footballers that have that have gotten
away with it you're believing women you
don't even know